hello and welcome everyone my name is
jonas corla i'm chief scientific officer
at
pacific biosciences and i'd like to
thank the organizers for letting me
speak at the
lab roots virtual genetics week
this week i'd like to tell you in this
talk about how long high five reits
can aid in high quality the novel genome
assemblies
and this talk will not be focused on
kovat19 related research
mainly however i did want to mention
that high quality
genome assemblies are a great utility to
understand the virus and
biology here are two examples of a
preprint and a published paper
about high quality pec viral assemblies
in bats and i understand it's maybe not
exactly clear where the pandemic virus
came from but
there's a strong indication that may
have been bats and the paper on the
right you can see
is specifically analyzing the high
quality pegbio
assembly for the remarkable
abilities of bats to deal with all sorts
of viruses
including coronavirus and then of course
i also wanted to mention right in the
beginning that model organisms of course
are critical in virology
research and having a high quality
genome for these model organisms be it
macaques or suri mangabees and and so
forth
uh is critical to understand the immune
response and so there are
also several papers listed here and
while the rest of the presentation is
not focused on kobit 19
i did want to mention that and if you
have an organism
a complex organism that you would like
to get a high quality
genome assembly for i hope that this
triggers your interest and and perhaps
some of the following
work that i will describe will be of
interest i will talk in quite some
detail about human genome assemblies
and of course understanding the human
genome and how it responds to the
viruses is very critical
so with that i'll uh and so i wanted to
mention we have a
web page resource pacb.com code19
where you can get a lot more information
about corporate 19 related
research and please everyone stay safe
so with that i'll start the presentation
um i meant you see that there's hifi
reads in the title
and so high five reads are both long and
accurate sequentially
and that's really a shift in the world
that we've been living in
where you have a short and accurate um
say illumina reads and then long and
noisy reads from back bio and
oxford nanopore and about a year ago we
have
changed this paradigm by virtue of the
fact that we can now
get very long and also highly accurate
on
sequence reads and the way this is done
is on the upper left you see a double
stranded piece of dna
most of you will be familiar with this
you ligate these hairpin adapters and
then the
polymerase in smart sequencing opens
that structure and
goes into a rolling circle synthesis
mode which you can see on the right
which creates these subreads of the
forward and the reverse strand and while
those
are themselves somewhat noisy what's
important is that the errors that are
indicated by the red dots are random and
so you can take a consensus
from this individual molecule and end up
with a hi-fi read
that we define as a read that's greater
than 99
accurate and so then in the context of
the
technology evolution that i have put
here
we've always had these um so-called
circular consensus sequencing or hifi
reads
however the read length was not long
enough until recently to make that
really
viable for long inserts and in the
box on the left you can see that over
the course of the last 10 years we've
increased
both the throughput by over 10 000 volts
but what's relevant here
is the read length by over a hundred
volts and so what that means now is that
you can really get very long polymerase
reads that give you
um very powerful high fires and so
specifically since october with the
latest
version two chemistry we have increased
the efficiency
of the polymerase going into this
rolling circle synthesis
increase the read length even further
thereby increasing the yield of these 99
or greater or q20 leads and
increase the insert size up to right now
about 25 kilobases and so that makes it
really useful
to consider now beyond targeted
sequencing where it's played a role for
quite some time
but also now for um genome assembly
and so all of this happens on this uh
sequel 2 system
and you can see here the smart cell 8m
that's the where the magic happens and
the
where the sequencing happens and we
introduced the sql 2 system
pretty much exactly a year ago and it
has higher throughput compared to the
original sql system
it's really tuned to providing these
hi-fi
highly accurate long leads and because
of the higher throughput
there's reduced time for faster results
to get more affordable and so forth
so in the context of the many
applications that can now be completed
with just one or two smart cell atms
what this talk will be focusing on is
just the lenovo assembly part
and so i mentioned that um a little over
a year ago was the first application of
these
uh this new type of read sequence reads
for high fides to the human genome
a preprint was posted in january that
described this type of read and showed
on the human genome
that it is now possible to get high
precision and recall for
all types of genetic variation single
nucleotide variants indels and structure
variants
you can phase those variants into
haplotypes access regions in the genome
that were pretty
previously not accessible for example in
the medical exome and also
the first highly accurate lenovo
assembly was shown
and so this paper published on the upper
left you can see in nature biotechnology
later in 2019 and since then there have
been quite a number of either
publications or preprints that i'm
showing here
that have leveraged on this new type of
sequence data
these hyper reads and so um the latest
um
preference is the one on the right um
from
sergey korn and adam philippe just a few
weeks ago and so this is a very good um
both sort of reflection of where the
state of the art is now
and also of course done by a customer
and so it's an independent validation
and so
this is available so i'm going to go
through this rather quickly but
sergey and adam and their collaborators
observe that icano is capable of
generating the most accurate and
complete human genome assemblies to date
on the right you see a figure where the
high canoe assemblies um this is the
high canoe is the assembler that
sergey and his colleagues wrote
specifically for these hi-fi data
and um you can see on the x-axis the top
point there is at about
19 kilobase insert length um we're
getting pretty close to the
actual theoretical maximum which is um
the
top um horizontal line there that's the
best you can do
in terms of contiguity because there's a
limited size of the chromosomes in the
human genome and you can see that it's
getting pretty close to that
the paper shows that with regard to
repeat resolution
the high canoe assembly has the highest
level of resolution of these
bacterial artificial chromosomes or
backs that are
representing segmental duplications so
those are some of the most
challenging repeat regions in genomes
because they're highly homologous
and there's a direct comparison of the
orange and the purple
of 30 fold in both cases
in orange is pec bio with high canoe and
in
purple is 30 folds of ultra long
nanopore reeds
and you can see that for all three
genomes one on the left
the haploid and the two on the right are
diploid genomes
there's much better resolution of these
really challenging repeat regions with
the hi-fi data
and so this is a nice example
demonstrating that you can
trade uh read length for accuracy if
your wreaths
become accurate enough those repeats
resolve
by themselves and um you can get
substantially better
uh resolution and quality of the genome
assembly
they looked at other um repeat types um
and
found that both canoe and high canoe
assemblies of the hi-fi data
um consist of four contacts with
structural errors in this particular
example that's shown on the right
that's the defensin gene cluster that
plays a role about
defense for microbials
and you can see in green there canoe and
high canoe
resolve that correctly whereas other
assemblers or the ont data have errors
which are indicated in red or gaps
which are indicated in white and they
looked at other
repeat classes had good recovery of all
human repeat classes
that's shown here on the right now here
less is better because here these are
remaining collapse spaces so you want to
have as few as possible and again an
orange on the pec bio hifi data have
substantially less compared to
for example the the nanopore data and
then the numbers
in the uh bar uh in the bars
represent the consensus accuracy so
uh q55 or greater versus 227
for nanopore that's a factor of about
820 fold better
with the pec buyer hifi data there are
explicit tables in the paper
showing the high quality of greater than
q50
in the um in these assemblies so that's
99.99
accurate or less than one error in 100
000 basis
compared to other technologies which are
substantially more error-prone
in the final assembly and the quotes
down on the bottom are taken from the
paper to indicate
that these assemblies by themselves with
just one technology are so accurate
that they no longer require polishing or
shortcut data
and actually the authors discourage
polishing because it actually introduces
errors during the polishing step
so just with the pacquiao hifi data
alone you get a complete
a contiguous and an accurate genome
assembly
and um it was shown i think that's very
exciting
that regions that were previously
unsequenceable and and
not antiquable but were not um it was
not possible to assemble them
are now becoming accessible so this
preprint
provides the first preliminary
assemblies of nine complete human
centromeric regions
and there's one example shown here from
a figure in the paper so
again highlighting that there are micro
heterogeneities
in these highly repetitive regions and
the hi-fi data are accurate enough to
resolve those
and can be used in a de novo assembly
context with just one technology
to put that together correctly on the
other end of the chromosome of course
you have telomeres
and um this is a different paper um by a
preprint by chris mason who specifically
looked at
telomeres with these hifi data and
this preprint reports the first motif
composition maps of human telomeric
diplotypes on the multi-kilo-based scale
so of course the human genome is diploid
so you have two copies of each
chromosome
and what this figure here shows is that
the hifi data are so good
and so accurate that you can actually
differentiate
the telomeres of those two um
chromosomes from all these chromosomes
the two alleles
which is what not possible uh chris
mason also
compared on the two technologies um the
pec bio ccs that's another term for hifi
um and the proles ion and found that
there's
uh substantially better quality and
resolution
and the correct assignment and
resolution and characterization of the
telomeres compared to the
other long-range technology so in the
following i want to tell you a little
bit more about how this
how this looks in practice and um i'm
using an example of an ongoing
collaboration
and work that was really led by tina
lindsey fulton ira hall and chris
markovitz from the mcdonald team
institute from washington university
um tina gave a talk at the hbt
conference
and some of the slides
that she presented i want to share with
you here as well so this is on
a well-characterized human genome na
19240 which is a reuben an african
genome
and so they sequenced um and here's a
representative example of the sequencing
performance
on the left you see um the raw reads
um you so you see most of the data is
from polymerase reits that are known
excess of 200 000 bases and so that
allows you to generate very high quality
and
long hi-fi rates that's in the middle of
the average
insert length of the dna fragments about
18 kilobases
and on the right is the equality so the
x-axis there
is the accuracy so q20 on the left and
q30
240 and so forth and the number of reads
and so these these uh statistics graphs
are nice but they don't really reflect
very well
of what a hifi read really looks like so
what i thought i would do is
show you one and uh so what i've done
here is taken
an average or the from the from the mode
of both of these distributions you can
see that on the upper right
so i took an 18 kilobase read that has
the typical accuracy which is about q35
and i've just printed it here and so
this is the whole wreath
18 342 bases and
you can predict from the number of turns
and number of times the polymerase went
around the smart cell
what the accuracy of that lead will be
and the predicted qe is 35.
and so now we can map that read against
the denoble assembly and ask
you know what what's was that a good
prediction and what's the right answer
and we find that out of those 18
342 bases 18 336 were correct and there
were six
errors which are indicated by the red uh
little triangles and that computes to
99.967 percent accurate for this
particular height
i read qe 34.85 so that's that's right
on the money so
so you can see that uh they're
in these hi-fi reads thousands of bases
and stretches that are
perfectly accurate and uh there are only
very few errors remaining
and that really i hope visualizes a
little bit better the power
that you can use this new type of data
of long and accurate sequence rates for
the normal assembly
and so they ran for smart cells because
they wanted to over sample to see how
that
would look with regard to the coverage
requirements
you can see it's quite uh steady and
robust about 1.6 to 1.8 million
hi-fi reads about 10-fold coverage of
the human genome
i mentioned 18 kb and the mo the median
quality is
q30 we have made improvements that i
quickly want to mention about the
compute times and the
assemblers that can be used so there's
now a dedicated falcon
assembler that is optimized for sequence
accuracy phasing accuracy and speed
using modern tools
and so then here's the result and so you
can pause and read the numbers in detail
but
um the summary is a very high quality
genome assembly with almost 30 megabase
contact and 50
correct genome size and what i do want
to highlight is the second column of
haplotypes so
87 of this genome
was separated into the two haplotypes
so this is going to the notion that the
human genome size is not three gigabases
but six gigabases because you have two
copies
and obviously they're not the same one
is from the mother and one is from the
father
and um this is going very close to
completely
resolving and characterizing both
alleles separately
and getting a much better picture of the
biological reality
of what is inside a cell and that's six
gigabases of sequence and not three
and so here's an example of how clean
the data looks you can see in this igb
shot each row is an individual hi-fi
read
they're grouped in to the two alleles so
the upper panel is the
you know one of the alleles and you can
see in this purple with
numbers um that there is a heterozygous
deletion i think it's 500
base pairs um and so you can see
how nicely the both heterozygous and
homozygous snips
are how clean the data is and how well
they're phased
um the last thing i want to mention is
the compute requirements are much
reduced with hifi data
um here's again a busy table that i wish
uh encourage you to pause and then you
can look at all these numbers but
in a nutshell only 14 of the input file
size because the hi-fi data already
highly accurate and then in terms of the
overall
compute time and the disk usage much
reduced
compute requirements and so that makes
the assemblies faster
you don't need as much expense and time
storing the data and so forth i
mentioned that the researchers
sequence for smart cells and so they
wanted to see when the performance
really plateaus
and so you can see we ran assemblies for
one
two three and four cells included in the
data and you can see that at about
there's two cells you already get a
really good assembly with 22 megabase
contact and 50 the correct genome size
and then you get a little bit more um if
you want to really
um go to the max three cells
insufficient there's
really very marginal improvement after
that but
two cells already give you a if you want
to balance
a budget and quality two cells
gives you a really nice assembly and
then lastly
on the human side i want to mention that
we are um working on
more advanced assemblers um and my
colleagues have cronenberg and
his colleagues had a blog post that's on
the bottom i
encourage you to check out we are
working on new assemblers that directly
include the phasing in the assembly
string graph so that
avoids one round of an assembly and it's
faster
and he's got very encouraging results
already for drosophila
and uh is now extending that to human
so that was on de novo assembly on the
human side and so now i want to talk a
little bit about plant and animal
sequencing and so
for that we have to go all the way back
because um while it's fairly
straightforward
to get samples and to get good quality
dna
for human samples it's much more
challenging for the
wide variety of sample types and tissue
types and the biodiversity
with animals and plants and so
to help to try to help the community we
have looked at the available literature
on dna extraction protocols that have
published
in conjunction with pect biosequencing
we've put this on the website
called extract dna from pegbio.com
and so this is just a resource of links
and the links directly point to the
method so they don't go to the top of
the paper
when available they go directly to the
method section and so you click on it
and so there's the sample extraction in
this case
pufferfish and so forth so if you have
any protocols that work really well for
you and that you would like to
contribute to this
site please email on the bottom you see
there extractdnamp.com
and also if you have any questions or
feedback please contact
us other than that with regard to
library prep
updates hi-fi is now the new standard
for all
genome projects and because excuse me
because we have found that it gives
higher quality compared to the previous
um clr mode with regard to contiguity
completeness and correctness
there's one library prep for all the
hi-fi workflows it's called
the express template replicate 2.0 and
we realized that some organisms are
small so last year we collaborated with
ammar lonisack and matt berryman from
the sanger institute and developed a low
input protocol
that goes down to about 100 nanograms
and
is then available for insects in
particular
and um mark blackster who has the
dormant tree of life
program at the sanger institute
presented this
at the pac conference showing 44 new
butterfly effect our assemblies this
talk was recorded and the link is down
in the bottom
here all with much better quality than
what had been previously done
in lepidoptera also at pax there was a
hi-fi assembly of the tetrafloyd rose by
barton island from gene twister
and this is just a slide again the clock
is recorded and it's on the bottom
showing the difference between the short
read assemblies with aluminum on the top
where it's really difficult to resolve
the four
alleles um roses tetraploid
whereas on the bottom you can see how
clearly you can group
the different alleles into their on the
reads into the four
different alleles and you can see all
the variation the
heterozygous snips and the structural
variants really nicely
and then we were quite amazed kevin
fengler i was really
adventurous and courageous and applied
hi-fi reads to the 11 gigabyte oat
genome
that was much bigger than what we would
have attempted at the time
and uh you can see from the screenshot
that was taken apart
uh 20 megabase contin 50 with just eight
smart cells 22 full coverage
uh so really quite amazing and so
inspired by
by his presentation and by sergey korn's
preprint and so forth
uh we then embarked and wanted to see
how well hi-fi data could do on a really
large genome so we selected the
california redwood genome project
and my colleagues michelle
led by michelle vieira went out to
stanford collected some leaves and
within 17 days
um generated the peculiar hifi assembly
that was substantially better
and much faster you can see on the table
here the first column
are the metrics for the kelp for the
pacquiao hifi assembly in the middle
column
is the same coverage uh a nanopore
assembly
um supplemented with 124 coverage of
short reads
um that took five to six months whereas
our assembly was done in six days
and uh the contiguity
is um almost 20 fold better and so forth
so we were very pleased
and demonstrated that you can do this
hi-fi paradigm for the novel assembly
really or very complex and very large
genomes
and then uh we realized that for some
organisms are even smaller and you can't
even get 100 nanograms
from single individuals which are much
preferred for the novo assembly and so
we have an ultra low dna
input workflow that goes to about five
nanograms of samples
this is currently in early access it
does require some amplification
and we have some kits um we are in early
access if you're interested you can get
in touch with us
and we can see whether after the
pandemic and the world opens again
whether we can work together and testing
this we have collaborated with
researchers from notre dame and uc davis
demonstrating that this can be done
uh very nicely on a very tiny fly a
single sand fly
starting with five nanograms getting to
an assembly that you can see on the
right and the contact in 50 or greater
than the megabase
and good completeness and contiguity and
accuracy as well
i just want to mention that for the
human for something like
cancer needle biopsies for example
this also might be of interest where you
only have a few cells and only five
nanograms
and this is the comparison of the pec
bio ultra low to the standard protocol
it's a little bit worse but still pretty
good in terms of
recalling and with precision with regard
to single nucleotide polymorphisms in
delts and structure variants so
even in some cases where the organism is
large
um circumstances like a needle biopsy
may dictate that you only get very
few nanograms of dna so this protocol
might be
of interest in those contexts as well
and then we have a very exciting
additional collaboration also with the
saenger institute chris omar who's here
on the right
and we started collaborating he's
interested in very tiny platforms
that he collected on the left you can
see the river cam just behind the senger
institute
and what's really amazing is that um
on the picture on the right is the
actual individual
that was sequenced with the protocol
that he developed
um so now this is much lower this is
about 100 picograms or so
and um he did the extraction of the dna
ran his protocol and then it was
sequenced at the singer institute and we
worked together on the assembly and for
this little critter
uh the contigan50 was also over one
megabase so really quite
remarkable i'm very grateful that chris
allows me to
present the results of this
collaboration so the redwood
one of the very largest species and this
is getting to pretty small uh eukaryotes
as well everything can be covered really
nicely for high quality genome
assemblies
using pic bio so with that um i was
talking about dna and genome assembly
in the last two minutes i just want to
mention that of course your genome is
only
as good as you can then annotate it and
for that um
our isoseq method in the rna sequencing
realm
it's very powerful and has been used
extensively for those of you who don't
know what icc
is full-length rna sequencing you can
read about the
characteristics here we now have updated
kits that make this easy
fast reduced input requirements and
reduced
costs and with the increased throughput
of the sql 2 system
in many cases you only need one smart
cell run to fully characterize the
transcriptome structure in this case you
see the
curved plateau for the human
transcriptome and then there are other
tools to phase
the transcripts into their respective
alleles
or even detect epigenetic modifications
on the rna which is shown on the bottom
right there's a paper there
so this has been used quite extensively
for many
uh plant and animal and also human
examples i'm just showing a few here
uh looking at allele isoform expression
tissue-specific isoform expressions
answering specific questions about
biosynthetic capabilities for example in
cannabis
or hibernation for the grizzly bear so
there are a lot of papers
check out our website on isis seek if
you're interested
and it's a very powerful tool to
annotate your genomes
so with that i'd like to thank you for
your attention thank you for joining
this talk
um and i understand you can email
you know or submit questions and then
they will be emailed and i'll be very
happy to be in touch
and answer those and i look forward to
hearing from you
thank you very much
you